so much goes on in nature
and what you have to calm down to see it
i mean you have to
really calm down
and sometimes i think the power of
of low doses of psychedelics is simply
that they make people sit down shut up
and pay attention
and that you know i
amazing things go on
my brother once was testing uh
i can't even remember what it was some
drug
of not great interest but it oh i know
what it was it was it was ritalin which
is a psychic energy smoothing thing and
this was 15 years ago or so and he just
sat down
like this
and
waited to experience and study the
effects of this compound
and
as he settled into this calm state
a spider
came
and
wove an orb web between his fingers
right here and he just sat and watched
this thing and it took an hour
and you know it was it talked about dao
i had an experience once years ago again
this again be calmed by by a palestinian
of some sort but not particularly swept
away by visions but be calmed in nature
and at ease
sitting on a beach in the seychelles
islands again
with just my hands like this and uh a
crab
a small white crab came
and cleaned
under my fingernail
one by one they fought
you know and then there are other things
wave phenomena and these
stirrings and
it's
like what we said yesterday about
whitehead defining understanding as that
perception of pattern as such well
nature is pattern upon pattern on every
scale in energy and light in matter uh
in momentum in charge and electric field
and magnetic density it's just all there
to be known
and
and when you feel out into it i think
these kinds of general principles
are
are what emerge for you nature works
with such an incredible economy
and with such an incredible elegance
i mean there is no wasted energy this is
what dao means you know it means
an appropriate response to every
situation an appropriate
tool for every job
an appropriate
linguistic response to every situation
[Music]
[Music]
you